hello everybody I hope you are good
hello Market maker I know you are there
what a crazy day yesterday we were
talking about the idea of a shortage
squeeze because we were saying all these
weeks to the downside okay we had the
Confluence of all the weeks to the
downside and that usually means that
market making this bill in a position
in this case that would be a long
position
and also that after this aggressive pump
the market was quiet you know you locked
on on Twitter and and it was super quiet
There Was You Know Traders were scared
nobody was putting money on the table
and that means that the the big boys are
not making any profit on fees okay so of
course they have to move the market how
can they move the market well they have
to induce Traders
to open trades how did they do that well
with agreeing big candle okay that was
the logic also behind this move so we
had the psychology of the move with also
what we were saying in this song with
all this week so that was telling us
that there was going to be a short
squeeze and I upload that video I think
after just one hour it started to happen
of course you can say that we got all
the all the news about the grayscale ETF
but I think that was the cheering type
of Decay because if you guys go to the
let me go to the
to the SMP to the Futures okay you can
see that yesterday we also saw a huge
green candle okay so that's also why the
recent Bitcoin pumped in a way
okay of course uh the SMP is now doesn't
care about the grayscale Bitcoin ETF
okay so
um I'm telling you the pump was going to
happen
um grayscale
ETF
court case uh it's it's simply just you
know maybe pumped another two three
percent I don't care but by looking at
also the pump in the SMP it seems that
it was about to happen either way okay
that you can call it Catalyst call as
you want okay but the chart was there
first now if you look at the charter
there are some things that I like and
some things that I don't like
for example I don't like that in the
daily time frame we are testing the 50ma
as resistance you can see that okay
that's right now our main resistance we
went above the mid-range that's great
I'm very glad because now maybe price
can get back into the mid range and
maybe who knows who can hold their
support okay but the problem is that we
got rejected at the daily 50ma and
that's going to be your main resistance
at the moment now if we go to the
forward time frame this or sorry for
example the one hour time frame
this is something that I recommend you
doing uh you go to the aama you go to
settings and in time frame you can
select the the time frame you want the
EMA to be on for example during the one
hour time frame right now but you want
to show the fifth domain the daily time
frame so you click here the one day and
you can see in in your one hour time
frame you can see the daily 50ma okay
you can see that's your resistance at
the moment it's almost to the dollar you
guys can say there all right so that's
something that I don't like
also uh this change yep uh in the weekly
time frame what is the 50ma
well to be honest we are we're above it
right now okay but this candle closes on
Sunday night so you still have some days
and what I want to say here
is that I would like to see
a weekly candle close above the weekly
50ma otherwise if we retrace tomorrow
one we're gonna talk about in a minute
okay but if we have a retrace and you
close the weekly candle below
the quickly 50ma then you know still is
looking that you are you know might be
here for some time and then continue
dropping low okay
so that's one thing to keep an eye on
for this week I think this is the main
thing okay this week because to be
honest uh when we were above here you
know we were very far away from the
weekly 50 May for example in this one I
was telling you you want to pay
attention to the weekly 15 because if
you hold above it then you're gonna see
another pump and look what happened here
this weekly candle just close above that
and then
we saw the pump right so the same
applies here but inversely if you are
going to Fable lower prices then you
want to see the weekly 50 EMA acting as
resistance so you want to see this we
click handle closing below it if you
want to favor lower prices okay so then
you can maybe see some transaction like
this and then you see a final drop all
right
so that's the main thing uh to look out
for this week is the weekly 59 let's see
how the closest right now we're above it
but we still have some more days to go
okay
so
um that's pretty much everything in the
daily
um Google time frame now if we go into
the into the followers time frame I was
talking I think yesterday also about
this liquidity pool over here
okay you can see that we just felt it
there you go okay and then you added a
resistance again
so that's good thing also if you notice
here you have another liquidity pool
it's smaller by source of wallet okay
and that goes all the way to 28 500. so
pay attention to that zone okay and also
if you notice it's exactly where the
range size are okay
so that's when it's going to be the next
Zone to the upside if there is gonna be
a new high but again remember that you
have the uh the daily 50 mix so it's
gonna be quite complex okay but
if you go now into lower time frame what
do you see here okay first of all you
see a huge huge huge imbalance here
look at that imbalance it's it's insane
it's like a uh how much is this uh one
thousand two hundred dollar in Balance
this imbalance is huge do I think it's
gonna get filled sooner or later
uh to be honest yes guys I think it's
gonna get filled it's gonna get retraced
sooner
is it going to happen today
to be honest I don't think so
um I'll tell you what I think usually
you see a big pump like this okay and
then you either see a very sharp retrace
or as he's doing right now to be honest
it's coming down very slowly okay so I
think
that it's quite likely to be honest that
we see today maybe another pump
okay maybe towards this one it's not
much if we take it it will be maybe like
a
actually it's almost like a two percent
one and a half percent say okay say one
and a half percent
but this is something that we could see
today another one and a half percent
pump because we've already retraced from
here
a three percent okay so uh do I think
this free Trace is done
yes and no for today is done in the
midterm it's not because we still have
this massive imbalance here okay but I
do think that today
I'm gonna favor Longs I I again I might
be wrong with this one yesterday I was
right let's see today okay but take it
with a pinch of salt just because I took
the the call of yesterday right doesn't
mean that I'm gonna get today's score
right okay so for what I see here I
think that it's very likely that we go
to probably this soon over here and that
will take you around 27
800 okay
something like this I would like to see
today if I'm honest with you so that's
what I'm failing for today
um I think uh if we come take advantage
of this pump that would be nice okay uh
to be honest you know between one and a
half two percent probably will be it
will be lovely um that's what I'm
looking for today but I would like to
see what is it all are doing because
yesterday I marked in my chart a liquid
oh they took it half pelvis at least
okay
yeah pretty much half of the liquidity
pool was taken and then price dumped
okay uh that's it and I think this was
another good way to put that was taken
before
okay
so I mean
to be honest
let's see what it is
we are
um
uh well I don't know if I'm losing
support to be honest okay
because if you know TCM
usually you see one candle and Recovery
you see a week one calendar and then
recovery
here you're saying already four or five
candles
but to be honest here
you so the same okay and it's difficult
to tell because tomorrow on Thursday we
have a inflation report pce and then on
Friday we've got something even more
important in an opinion which is
non-farm payrolls because I think the
labor market is doing something
interesting I'm gonna talk about that
soon
but
uh be very careful on Thursday and
especially on Friday
because I think something big might
happen in the markets okay there is
going to be quality volatility I'll talk
about it again I don't know if it's
gonna be on a video or in Twitter but
I'll mention what I think about the
non-farm payrolls uh on Friday it's
going to be quite interesting okay so I
don't know what the dollar Index is
doing I don't know if he's doing
something similar to this
okay
or if it's going to continue going lower
and it's impossible to tell
okay if we didn't have this over here
then I will tell you based on what
happened previously
then yes we've lost support and we're
gonna go lower here okay but having what
happened here and this was probably
don't get me wrong this was probably
also during major news announcements
okay this pump over here you can say
that the pump is crazy okay I don't even
say something similar because I don't
know what the results are gonna be like
okay somebody can make it might no but I
don't
so be careful uh the most uh likely
thing my opinion is that the dollar
Index continues uh hanging around here
until the news announcements on Thursday
and Friday and then that's when you can
see a direction to the upside or
downside all right so be careful here
and of course there's a lot in this is
going to determine what Bitcoin does
next because Bitcoin trades against the
dollar right so if you go back to
bitcoin then that would make sense to
say that is very likely that they want
to hold in this Zone and that takes you
to the area that is likely that then
today you see this pump towards 20 27
800.
okay another reason why I'm gonna favor
a small long today because I think it's
very likely that we consolidate over
here okay to continue dropping now
before tomorrow on Friday we have major
mix major news announcements doesn't
make much sense to me it makes more
sense to hold in this Zone okay
um they can hold here but I think it's
more likely that they also attack this
Zone over here okay and yes this is also
holding
right so
um I hope that was clear I want to take
you to high blood capital
because it probably is gonna give us all
more information about the liquidation
levels and also the liquidation heat map
in lower time from so let's go there
okay first of all we're here in the
liquidation levels yesterday we were
saying that there was more liquidity to
the upside
and you can see that they took all of
the liquidity boom okay right now the
cumulative then ties around 11 billion
dollars
uh it's quite low but uh it's difficult
to tell if it's gonna if it's enough for
the market to reverse already of course
you can see some uh liquidations here to
the downside the boat again I think it
makes more sense that today we
considered it a bit more okay maybe that
small scalp to the upside and then on
Thursday or Friday we'll talk again to
see what can happen okay
but for today I'm not I don't think
we're gonna continue going lower and hit
these liquidations to the downside
that's just uh my instinct okay my
traded Instinct I might be wrong but
that's what I that's the logic that I'm
applying now the liquidation feedback in
12 hours time frame
interesting
look at that 27 850 that's the liquidity
that's where the liquidity is in the
very short time frame okay so that could
be another conference that we might see
uh higher prices today one uh
and in the seven days time frame
we took with our liquidity to the upside
we didn't take the one at 25 700.
uh I think they might be for later
um you are pretty close to this one to
be honest 28 550. but again
if we get here
it's going to depend also in the new
salons wins tomorrow and on Friday so uh
take this with a pinch of salt just
because it's there don't think we're
gonna get there the same as the reason
why when we were around this Zone
definitely we were so close to this they
didn't really go there okay they shifted
off this zone so be careful take it with
a pinch of salt
one month time frame okay the ones to
the downside
and the three months time frame this is
what I want to take you to
we were talking yesterday on Friday and
maybe in first people we've been talking
about this chart for quite some time
because there is a lot of liquidity here
around 24 200 then you see this week
but it misses for a couple of hundreds
that is not a coincidence it usually
isn't and I was telling you that the
idea is
to build more Liquidations in this Zone
before they make them move down here
so they're gonna hit more liquidations
that they could have done previously and
the only way to increase the liquidity
here remember that these are long
liquidations why it is the only way well
the only way is to induce traders to
open lungs how do you do that with a
bakery encounter and it happened
yesterday so you can see how the logic
behind the market
it's um
again I might be crazy I might be
getting all of this right just because
I'm crazy but I think that the markets
are logical I don't believe that because
you are saying about a pennant
it's going to give you a high
probability trade I think that if you
apply a bit of logic and try to think
how the big boys think
even if you're more of a clue what the
market might do next okay so again do I
think we're gonna come to this Zone
uh I think so okay but the same thing
that I thought that we want to see this
big green candle
all right so the most likely thing in my
opinion is like continue consolidating
here these liquidations are going to
increase and then you know do you need
another big news announcements uh
probably should be something to do with
uh the economy
something breaking maybe we'll talk
about that soon and then that's when you
can see that drop
okay might take weeks I've told you this
before it might take weeks it might take
months okay this is the three months
time frame this is very high time frame
this might take some time guys so be
patient you know trade level by level
you know you think this was
if you think this is Spike here what's a
coincidence that they didn't hit this
sun then you would have thought okay or
when I come to 24K next but if you apply
a bit of logic
then you would have thought the same as
me and I know some of you thought the
same okay that's quite odd that's not a
coincidence something is brewing here
and and I think what I happened already
but I was telling you that I thought
that it was because they wanted to
induce traders to open lungs so the
liquidation here can increase
that's how I see the market guys so uh
again if this can help you with your
trades that's good if you can inspire
you to learn this trading system uh
that's also great
um that's pretty much everything that I
have to tell you guys so thank you so
much for watching
and I'll see you soon